hello and welcome back this is HAF here
with Pop-A-Lock Northern Colorado and
the AutoPro pad G2 Turbo today we're
working on a 2015
Nissan Altima
I have our key here
program it Nissan USA
program Keys select from type Smart Key
System 20
you think this is type 1 program smart
Keys ignition is off hazards are going
all right and now we're in program mode
all right we're gonna press and hold the
start button until the ignition turns on
Amazon
turn the ignition off
press the start button until the light
starts flashing
press and hold the logo end
security light flashes five times
ignition off
and we forgot to look at the programmer
that whole time which is fine failed to
communicate because it's already done
programming all right
keys in
ignition on one more time ignition off
it's going to say key registration
complete
and just like that
[Music]
smart keys in 2015 Nissan Altima
lost Keys Auto prepared G2 Turbo
[Music]